Y ya imagino lo que se estarán preguntando...
Les daré la respuesta: sí, un poco como Melinda Gates,
(Risas)
pero con mucho menos dinero.
Mi madre aplicó la filantropía en nuestra comunidad
a través de una práctica que llamamos 'isirika'.
Apoyó la educación de decenas de niños
e invitó a muchos a vivir con nosotros en nuestra casa
para que puedan acceder a la escuela.
Movilizó recursos para construir la clínica de salud local
y el pabellón de maternidad lleva su nombre como homenaje.
Pero lo más importante,
se ganó el cariño de la comunidad por su capacidad organizativa,
porque organizó a la comunidad,
y específicamente a las mujeres
para encontrar la solución
a todo lo que se necesitaba.
Lo hizo todo a través de 'isirika'.
Repetiré esa palabra otra vez:
'isirika'.
Ahora es el turno de Uds. Díganlo conmigo.
(Audiencia) 'Isirika'.
Musimbi Kanyoro: Gracias.
Esa palabra es de mi idioma, el maragoli,
que se habla en el oeste de Kenia,
y ahora Uds. están hablando en mi idioma.
(Risas)
'Isirika' es una forma de vida pragmática
que practica la caridad,
el servicio
y filantropía, en conjunto.
La esencia de 'isirika'
es dejar muy en claro ante todos
que cada uno es el guardián de su hermana
y sí,
también el guardián de su hermano.
La responsabilidad mutua de cuidarse el uno al otro.
Una traducción literal y simple sería "generosidad equitativa",
pero el profundo significado filosófico
es el cuidado mutuo, del uno al otro.
Y ¿cómo se manifiesta el concepto de 'isirika'?
Crecí en una comunidad agrícola
en el oeste de Kenia.
Recuerdo vívidamente las muchas veces
en que la gente iba a la casa de un vecino enfermo,
para recogerle la cosecha.
Yo acompañaba a mi madre a eventos comunitarios
y a eventos de mujeres,
y hablábamos de las vacunas escolares,
de la construcción del centro de salud
y de otros temas importantes,
como la renovación de semillas para la próxima temporada de siembra.
Y a menudo, la comunidad se unía
y donaba dinero para que el hijo de un vecino pudiera ir a la escuela,
no solo dentro del país sino también en las universidades del extranjero.
Y es así que tenemos un cirujano.
El primer cirujano de mi país era de esa aldea rural.
(Aplausos)
Así que...
el efecto de 'isirika' fue la inclusión.
Nosotros, como niños, estábamos de pie junto a los adultos
aportando nuestro dinero,
y nuestros nombres quedaban registrados en el libro de la comunidad,
como el de todos los adultos.
Y luego crecí,
fui a universidades locales y en el extranjero,
obtuve títulos en uno y otro lado.
Me organicé
e hice trabajos a nivel internacional,
incursionando en el ámbito del desarrollo,
el trabajo humanitario
y la filantropía.
Y muy pronto,
'isirika' comenzó a mermar.
Se disipó
y luego simplemente desapareció.
En cada lugar,
aprendí un nuevo vocabulario.
El vocabulario de donantes y receptores,
medición de impactos,
rentabilidad de inversión,
proyectos y programas.
Las comunidades como mi comunidad natal
empezaron a ser consideradas "poblaciones pobres y vulnerables".
Esas son las comunidades que la literatura menciona
cuando se refiere a cómo vivir con menos de un dólar por día,
y se transforman en el blanco de los programas
para erradicar la pobreza.
Y por cierto,
son los mismas metas del primer objetivo
de desarrollo sostenible de Naciones Unidas.
Estoy realmente interesada
en encontrar soluciones a la pobreza
y a tantos grandes problemas del mundo, que sin duda los hay.
Sin embargo, creo que podríamos hacer un mejor trabajo,
y lo podríamos lograr adoptando el concepto de 'isirika'.
Les diré cómo.
Primero, 'isirika' predica la humanidad común.
Sea lo que sea que hagamos,
partimos de la premisa de que somos humanos cuando estamos juntos.
Cuando se comienza siendo humanos en conjunto,
nos vemos de manera diferente.
Lo primero que vemos en el otro no es a un refugiado,
tampoco a una mujer
ni una persona con discapacidad.
Primero, uno ve un ser humano.
Esa es la esencia de ver primero a una persona.
Y al hacerlo,
se valoran sus ideas,
su contribución,
pequeña o grande.
Y se valora lo que lleva a la mesa.
Esa es la esencia de 'isirika'.
Solo quiero imaginar qué pasaría
si todos los que están en esta sala,
un médico, un padre,
un abogado, un filántropo,
cualquiera sea su ocupación,
adoptasen el concepto de 'isirika'
y lo convirtieran en su premisa.
¿Qué podríamos lograr el uno para el otro?
¿Qué podríamos lograr para la humanidad?
¿Qué podríamos lograr para la paz?
¿Qué podríamos lograr para la medicina?
Les daré un par de pistas,
porque voy a pedirles que me acompañen
en este proceso de reconstrucción y recuperación de 'isirika'.
Primero, deben tener fe
de que somos una humanidad,
de que tenemos un solo planeta
y de que no tenemos dos opciones.
Y no habrá jamás un muro lo suficientemente alto
para separar a la humanidad.
Así que abandonen los muros.
Olvídenlos.
(Aplausos)
Y no tenemos un planeta B como otra alternativa.
Eso es realmente importante.
Quedando esto claro,
pasemos a la siguiente etapa.
La segunda etapa: recuerden,
en 'isirika', cada idea es importante.
Los puentes tienen grandes pilares
y tienen clavos.
Cada idea es importante,
las pequeñas y las grandes.
Y tercero,
según el concepto de 'isirika',
quienes más tienen disfrutan del privilegio de dar más.
Dar más es un privilegio.
(Aplausos)
Y este es el momento en que las mujeres deben dar más a las mujeres.
Es el momento de dar más a las mujeres.
Cuando nuestros padres traían a otros niños a vivir con nosotros,
no nos pedían permiso.
Dejaban claro que tenían una responsabilidad
porque habían ido a la escuela
y tenían un ingreso.
Y nos hacían entender
que su prosperidad no nos daba derechos,
y creo que es una sabia enseñanza de 'isirika'.
Podríamos usar esa sabiduría hoy, en cada cultura,
en cada lugar,
legando a la próxima generación lo que podríamos hacer juntos.
Y yo,
a través de los años,
encontré 'isirika' en muchos lugares,
pero lo que realmente me apasiona hoy
de adoptar la filosofía de 'isirika'
es el trabajo que hago con mujeres de todo el mundo
a través del Fondo Mundial para la Mujer,
con fondos destinados a la mujer
y a través de movimientos de mujeres a nivel mundial.
Si trabajamos con mujeres,
cambiamos todos los días
porque practican el concepto de 'isirika' cuando trabajan en conjunto.
En el trabajo que hago,
confiamos en las mujeres líderes y en sus ideas.
Y las apoyamos con fondos para que puedan desarrollarse,
crecer y prosperar dentro de sus propias comunidades.
En 1990, una mujer vino al Fondo Mundial con una gran idea,
una mujer de México llamada Lucero González.
Ella quería iniciar una fundación para respaldar un movimiento
que tuviera su origen en las comunidades en México.
Y recibió una subvención de USD 7 500.
Hoy, 25 años después,
"Semillas", el nombre de la fundación,
logró reunir e invertir en la comunidad
USD 17.8 millones.
(Aplausos)
Han alcanzado a más de dos millones de personas,
y trabajan con un grupo de 600 000 mujeres en México.
Durante el último terremoto,
estaban tan bien organizadas
que lograron evaluar muy rápido, en esa y en otras comunidades,
las necesidades a corto plazo y las necesidades a largo plazo.
Y les digo,
mucho después de que las luces se hayan apagado en México,
"Semillas" estará allí
con las comunidades, con las mujeres,
por un largo tiempo.
Y a eso me refiero:
a ser capaces de apoyar las ideas de las comunidades
que están instaladas dentro de su propio entorno.
Hace 30 años,
había muy pocos fondos destinados directamente a manos de mujeres
en sus comunidades.
Hoy celebramos 168 fundaciones de mujeres
por todo el mundo,
100 de las cuales están en este país.
Y esos fondos financian...
(Aplausos)
financian las organizaciones comunitarias de mujeres,
grupos liderados por niñas y mujeres,
y juntas hemos logrado, de manera colectiva,
dar USD 1000 millones a organizaciones dirigidas por mujeres y niñas.
(Aplausos)
Pero el desafío comienza hoy.
El desafío comienza hoy
porque en todas partes vemos a mujeres
organizadas bajo el concepto de 'isirika',
incluyendo mujeres que se organizan de la misma manera en TED.
Porque 'isirika' es la eterna sabiduría que vive en las comunidades.
Está presente en comunidades indígenas,
en comunidades rurales.
Y lo que 'isirika' inculca en las personas
es esa capacidad de confiar
y de avanzar en la agenda.
Aprendí tres cosas que quiero compartir con Uds.
a través de mi trabajo.
La primera es que si quieren resolver los problemas más grandes del mundo,
deben invertir en las mujeres y las niñas.
(Aplausos)
No solo multiplican la inversión,
sino que se preocupan por todos en la comunidad.
No solo por sus propias necesidades sino por las de sus hijos,
del resto de la comunidad,
de los ancianos,
y lo más importante
es que se protegen a sí mismas,
que es fundamental.
Y protegen a sus comunidades.
Las mujeres que saben cómo protegerse
saben lo que significa marcar una diferencia.
Y la segunda razón por la que se debe invertir en las mujeres y las niñas
es porque esto es lo más inteligente que podrían hacer
en este momento particular.
Y si vamos a tener
más de USD 350 billones
para el 2030,
esos dólares deben estar en manos de las mujeres.
Y así crecí con 'isirika'.
Mi madre era 'isirika'.
Ella no era un proyecto ni un programa.
Y ahora, se lo transfiero a Uds.
Lo podrán compartir con sus familias,
con sus amigos
y con su comunidad,
y adopten 'isirika' como una forma de vida,
como una forma de vida pragmática.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)